Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, good morning, church.
Happy belated thanksgiving.
You know, I enjoy singing that song, especially in light of
what we're going to talk about this morning,
but we have a great deal to be thankful for.
Amen. Well, um, this morning we're in the book of Psalms.
Pastor John was out this week for Thanksgiving.
Uh, starting next week we're gonna have a three week series
in the run up to Christmas called God with Us, and then
after the new year back into
our series on the book of one Samuel.
But right now, if you have a Bible, please turn with me to
the book of Psalm.
Psalms chapter 77, Psalm chapter 77.
And as you turn there, I just have a question for you,
whether you have ever experienced a solar eclipse.
I don't know if you've ever witnessed
or seen a solar eclipse.
We had one back in April, I believe it was,
and we traveled down, my family
and I traveled down to Dallas where we were in
what they call the path of totality.
It's where, you know, you're, you're in the center
of the shadow of the moon, obviously in an eclipse.
What happens is the moon moves between the earth
and the sun and it doesn't totally wash out the whole
planet, right?
It's localized.
There's a shadow that's cost, that's cast depending on
where you're standing and where on earth you are.
But this is a picture, uh, sorry, do we have the picture?
Yeah. Um, our, our own Mark Tyson, he's up here singing.
He's also a great photographer as well.
And he took this picture of the solar eclipse.
One of the things that I love about this picture is that
whenever you have the full eclipse, what you can see,
you cannot see the sun.
But there are certain details
that you can pick up in the absence
of the radiance of the sun.
If it's light and heat that's sort of temporarily obscured.
You can see the corona around the outline of the moon.
You can see solar flares and um,
and anyway, this is what happens in a solar eclipse.
The lights seem to go out, it gets darker,
the temperature drops and the animals even respond.
It's like knights beginning to set end
and then of course it doesn't.
It's like the sun has gone away. But of course it hasn't.
And here in Psalm 77, it's a little bit like that.
Sometimes we have the experience
where we feel like God has gone silent.
It's as though our spiritual life is experiencing
a, an eclipse.
It's like God has changed
or maybe vanished out of our lives.
Perhaps we even begin to ask questions about God that feel
dangerous and concerning.
They're painful. We feel like maybe God doesn't care
or he's not there, or he's no longer active.
But the thing that we need to remember
and call to mine is that this is only
a temporary feeling or experience.
It's something that we're experiencing
in the moment from our limited vantage point.
Just like you might experience in an eclipse, it feels dark,
it feels confusing or scary.
Or maybe it's like when the storm clouds roll
in and what do we say?
You get up and the day it's just bleak and dark
because the clouds cover the sky.
We say something like The sun is not out today.
But of course that is only our perspective.
Here's the good news about solar eclipses and about storms
and clouds and darkness in the world.
It never changes the fact that the sun
is always shining.
The sun is always shining.
And so it is with the goodness and the glory
and the unchangeable nature
and the unchanging love of the goodness of God.
That's why we just sang about it, that God is
so good no matter what we're going through.
God has not changed even if it sometimes
feels that way.
So I wanna read in Psalm chapter 77, which I think has a lot
to say about this.
And Psalm 77 I think really comes in two parts.
There's the first half and the second half.
And we'll read from verses one to nine.
I believe you could really include verse 10 in that as well.
But I'll mention that here in a moment.
We'll read first verses one to nine.
If you have a Bible, I would invite you
to please follow along.
I cry aloud to God, aloud to God,
and he will hear me in the day of my trouble.
I seek the Lord in the night.
My hand is stretched out without wearying.
My soul refuses to be comforted.
When I remember God, I moan.
When I meditate, my spirit faints say, law,
you hold my eyelids open.
I am so troubled that I cannot speak.
I consider the days of old. The years long ago.
I said, let me remember my song in the night.
Let me meditate in my heart.
Then my spirit made a diligent search.
Will the Lord's sper forever and never again be favorable?
Has his steadfast love forever ceased?
Are his promises at an end for all time?
Has God forgotten to be gracious?
Has he in anger shut up his compassion?
Sayah, please join me in prayer.
Almighty God, we thank you this morning
for the light of your word.
Lord, we thank you for Psalm 77
and the reminders that we will find here.
I pray, God that you would speak it to our heart.
Now, in Jesus' mighty name, amen.
Well, Psalm 77, if you study it is categorized as
what we would call a biblical lament.
Now a lament is simply a saying or a song or a poem
or an expression of pain.
Lament can be, it can be Christian or otherwise.
It can just be saying, I feel bad,
I am in trouble, I have distress.
And that's just what a lament can be.
It can be grief and sorrow of any kind.
But what's different in the Bible, especially in the Book
of Psalms when we have biblical laments, is
that there is that kind of an expression of sorrow
and grief that is real and deep and tangible.
But there's also another layer that's really important
and it's the second layer that makes it uniquely biblical.
So the first part, scholars would say in a biblical event,
you have the passion that exists there.
That's the suffering and the sorrow
and the grief, the circumstance, the lament.
But you also have a progression.
You have a moving away from that, a starting point of grief,
but then there is movement away from that
upward and toward God.
And so that's what we see in a biblical lament.
It moves from obvious pain
to overt praise.
It moves from sighing on the one hand
to singing on the other.
It moves from today's sorrow to tomorrow's joy.
It moves from a crisis of faith
to a confidence in God.
It starts low and it goes high.
There's progress.
It's always going somewhere no matter where you start.
And I think this is the invitation of Psalm 77.
It's the admonition of Psalm 77.
No matter where you start, always move Godward,
always move, move godward.
So in a biblical lament also, it's not merely complaining
or venting or lamenting or emoting like we might sing.
I've got friends in low places or there's a tear in my beer
'cause I'm crying for you dear.
Wait, there's a Baptist church.
Okay, um, well, you know, some of you know that song.
I have no doubt. Okay, that's too lament.
But in a biblical lament, we're moving towards God
from a place of pain.
We're not just staying there. So it's instructive.
A verse, a chapter like this, it's formative.
I mean, think about this. Psalm 77 has been around
for likely 3000 years,
originally written in the Hebrew language translated into
thousands of languages across the planet and through time.
And so for thousands of years, these words
have both instructed and taught
and shaped God's people
and how we view our circumstances
and also how we approach God from a place of suffering.
And that brings us ultimately to my first point
here this morning is that when we experience grief
or sorrow, the kinds of things that would cause you
to lament, uh, the thing that we wanna see here is
to not be surprised, but that we ought to expect
that our faith is going to be tested.
So that's the first point, is that you should expect
your faith to be tested.
You know, as a new believer, I remember being shocked, uh,
fra frankly, I remember being rocked by some of the grief
that came my way spiritually speaking.
I'd felt I'd experienced God in a really new and unique way
and delivered from sin and struggles
and all kinds of things.
And it was like clear skies and my life had changed.
I started to follow Jesus and live a Christian life.
And then some of the old things began to creep in.
There was spiritual darkness or bad circumstances,
and I was struggling with God.
I remember struggling deeply with that. I was discouraged.
I was calling out to God like, Hey, this isn't working.
Where's God? You know, that's how I felt.
And, but ultimately I remember coming out the other side of
that experience,
what the ancients might call the dark night of the soul.
I remember coming through that for the first time
and feeling again, a sense
of encouragement I hadn't known before.
I feel a sense of strength.
I didn't know I felt like I knew God better.
I felt like I loved God more genuinely for
who he actually is.
And, and I sensed at a deeper level his love for me.
And uh, and
and frankly, this is a cycle
that I could say has repeated itself in my life
in a number of different ways.
And um, you know, if you're a believer here this morning,
then I, I assume you probably know this kind of cycle
that I'm talking about.
You've experienced this. If you haven't, how's the saying?
Go. Just wait. It's coming. Right?
And then for some of you, you're there right now for some
of you here in this room or listening to my voice,
you're here right now.
You're suffering struggling.
You're asking God questions you never thought you'd ask.
You're having feelings.
You're, you're having concerns
that maybe have never crossed your mind
towards God as a believer.
And yet here you are.
And my hope and my prayer is that this morning in Psalm 77,
you will be encouraged by God's word.
And may the spirit of God work in all of us to strengthen us
and encouraged us in our faith.
These, these trials
that come our way, they're often different.
They're never fun, they're always hard.
But absolutely our first point again is
that they should be expected.
I mean, just listen to the words of Jesus in John 16.
In this world you will have trouble.
But take heart, I have overcome the world.
And one Peter the apostle says, beloved, do not be
surprised at the fiery trial when it comes upon you
to test you
as though something strange was happening to you.
But instead, rejoice insofar
as your you share in Christ's suffering,
that you may also rejoice
and be glad when his glory is revealed.
And of course, James chapter one which says,
count it all joy my brothers, when you meet trials
of various kinds for you know this,
this is not something you suspect or hope
or wonder If you've read your Bible, we know it's clear.
We know that the testing of our faith produces something.
And it's not just sorrow, it's going somewhere.
It produces and creates steadfastness in us.
And the admonition here is let steadfastness have its full
effect so that you may be perfect
and complete, lacking in nothing.
Are you perfect and complete?
Then you're a work in progress.
And God is using these things in your life and mine to shape
and mold us to become more like him so
that he can use us in the world the way he's called
us to serve him.
So expect your faith to be tested.
I mean the opposite is this.
If you do not expect that your faith will be tested,
then what?
What will be your experience?
I think it's like Peter said,
you will think it's strange when it happens.
You will think it's abnormal or unusual
and you'll question God and you'll be deeply discouraged.
And I would say, you know, well ask questions like this.
Why would God allow this?
Why would God use this tool to form you
and to shape me to be more like who he is called us to be?
Why? Well, I think the answer becomes crystal clear.
It's because God deeply loves you.
It's because God loves you and he cares about you.
And he's thinking about you not merely in the moment,
but he's thinking about what he's doing in
and through your life, not only now,
but throughout all eternity.
He's a very long timeline in mind and,
and we are under construction if you will.
So God loves you and he wants to stretch and strengthen
and mature you to grow and deepen your faith.
If your faith is like roots going out from a tree,
the deeper and the further they go,
the stronger the tree is going to stand.
So when the storms come, they can take it.
Just think about like an illustration.
Think about the way that toddlers learn to walk, right?
We they, they begin to walk and we're so excited
and we, we hold them and guide them
and we catch them for a little while.
You know? So any of you, if you've had
children, what do you do?
At some point, you're so mean that you stop catching them.
You stop holding and guiding them and what happens?
They fall on their rear, right?
They fall on their face, they get bumps and bruises.
I mean, sometimes you worry like
you're like, what are people gonna think?
Like my kids hit his head five times this week
and it shows bumps and bruises.
Well, you know, God is a loving father
and he wants us to learn
to walk as we follow him.
And he allows at times, bumps and bruises along the way
because he is, has in view the maturity that's happening,
the progress that's taste taking place.
And so the Lord is doing this
as a loving father in our lives.
You could think about the refiners fire
where the heat's turned up
and the impurities rise to the top of the gold or silver
and that's removed and it becomes more pure
and precious where you think about the, the steel
that's folded in on itself
and mixed together to become stronger and harder.
Or it's like why some of you guys lift weights.
We call it resistance training, right?
Because if you do enough of it,
it makes you feel weak in the process.
But what's happening is you're actually getting stronger.
Psalm 77, what we experience here, the author is Asaf,
this psalmist, he has some unspecified struggle
that he's crying out to God about.
But you know, I think it's a mercy of God
that he doesn't detail what the struggle is.
If he said, Hey, I'm worried about paying the mortgage,
or I'm worried about my health,
or I'm worried about my kids, then we would say, when I have
that specific problem, I would go to Psalm 77 and pray this.
But the mercy of God is
that we don't know what his problem is.
So it means every problem, every distress that you have,
you can read this psalm
and you can draw near to God through its words.
And so we read here,
we just hear this guy praying and crying out to God.
The first four verses, it says, I cry aloud to God,
aloud to God and he will hear me.
So first he's just pleading with God
and in fact he's vocalizing this.
And I would encourage you, if you've never done this,
if you only ever pray in the privacy of your own heart
and mind, I would say if you have to get outside
or like Jesus said, go to your closet,
I would pray out loud just like you would speak to anyone
and pray to God out loud.
But here, right here in the first verse, there is a seed
of faith that exists.
He says, he will hear me.
What? He would not even bother to pray if he didn't think
that there was a hope that God is listening and that God can
and will respond.
Verse two, in the day of my trouble, I seek the Lord.
This is what I do in the night.
My hand is stretched out without wearing my soul.
It refuses to be comforted.
Either he is not going to relent in his pursuit of God
or he's so exhausted from his pursuit of God.
His soul is not being comforted.
When I remember God, I moan, when I meditate,
my spirit faints.
He's overwhelmed. This is painful.
Verse four, you hold my eyelids open.
I'm so troubled that I cannot speak.
Think about the distress that this man feels.
Some of you know what it feels like
to feel like God is prying your eyes open.
You're trying to sleep and rest.
You know, the experts say if you just get
some sleep, it will help.
And you say, well I'm trying
but I'm, I feel like God's holding my eyes open
and so I can't get sleep.
I need sleep. I'm so distressed
and weighed down and burdened.
I can't even speak or think.
This brings us to our second point, which is this, cry out
to God with honesty and with humility.
You know, this chapter is an example to us to be real
and honest with God.
You know, if we don't, if we're not honest with God,
we're frankly just fooling ourselves.
You know, sometimes we want to,
we think it doesn't sound spiritual
or religious to you know, we, we gotta sort
of put on a show towards God and and he's not fooled it all.
We wanna stuff that.
But it's like what one author said to do that is both it.
It's pious and poisonous.
So it looks religious, it looks spiritual
to not really be honest.
But then what happens is we just hold that inside
and it goes sour inside.
It's like painting over mold or some other contamination
or putting a bandaid on cancer, right?
It doesn't change it.
It doesn't fix it, it only masks it for the moment.
ASAP doesn't pretend to feel any better than he does
and it's just a good reminder to us that we ought
to be emotionally honest with God.
Even if you can't be with other people, you, you can be
and we should be with God.
So honestly, crying out to God
and also humbly crying out to God, he's the author here,
is groaning, he's moaning, right?
But the truth is, it's not the same thing.
To groan, to even groan towards God is not the same thing as
what the Bible would call grumbling.
So if you've read the Old Testament,
you know often God's people were judged and condemned
because they were grumbling against Moses and Aaron
or against God himself.
What, what's the difference between groaning
and grumbling in that place?
Well, I think grumbling is a settled
opinion and disposition.
It's like we're talking to each other
and saying, my mind is made up.
I'm mad at God because he's like this.
I'm talking about God and not to him.
But groaning and moaning is an expression of prayer to God.
Like, oh God, I'm hurting, I'm dying.
I need your intervention. There's faith involved in that.
So we do so humbly, we're not accusing God.
It's not proud or haughty like he owes me something.
But it's dependent.
It's like we would say here we are desperately dependent
on God and this is a way we can express that.
So we cry out to God with honesty and humility.
Our third point is that we remember
who God has proven himself to be.
Now the word, remember if you have this, have a Bible
and a pen or a piece of paper, write the word remember
and circle it in big bold colors
because the word remember is featured
prominently in Psalm 77.
In fact, it's repeated in a variety of places and time.
I think it's four or more times that it appears specifically
as the word remember.
And anytime you see a word like this repeated in the Bible,
it's a good clue
to understand what's happening in this chapter
or what's happening in the section.
It's a guide to know I ought to pay attention.
This is something that I'm going to need
to do or to think about.
So this comes in four parts.
And the first is that we ask genuine
questions of God.
It's not wrong to ask God genuine questions.
We see the author doing this right here
specifically I'll just read in verses seven through nine.
As he begins to unfold his questions, he says,
sorry, in verse five, I consider the days of old
the years long ago.
I said, let me remember my song in the night.
Let me meditate in my heart.
Then my spirit made a diligent search.
So he is beginning to look and search
and ask these questions, will God spur forever
and never again be favorable?
Has his steadfast love forever ceased?
Are his promises at an end for all time?
Has God forgotten to be gracious?
Has he in anger shut up his
compassion sayah?
Now as you hear those questions like I do,
what I hear is painful haunting questions.
These are verses that can be hard to read,
much less hard to pray.
And some of you know what I'm talking about
because you've asked these questions in the night,
you may have asked them this morning,
and these are questions
that are haunting, challenging questions.
And yet he lays them
before the Lord knowing that God will hear him.
He's not asking these hiding, he's not grumbling
but groaning and he's asking these questions
as he's searching his heart.
So we begin by asking genuine questions.
You know right here in verse 10, it's actually the end
of this section of his asking.
I'm reading from the English standard version,
which I think actually doesn't translate this well in in
verse 10 in the ESV.
It says, then I said, I will appeal to this to the years
of the right hand of the most high.
And that sounds good
and it really latches onto the rest of the chapter.
That's where we're going is that he's going to begin
to appeal to what he has seen and heard
and known that God has done in the past.
But if you are in the esv, there's a footnote that shows
that this is translated differently when you take it
literally in the Hebrew.
And so if you're reading the New American standard version
or the Christian Standard Bible,
or almost any other translation takes it this way, it says,
this is my grief that the right hand
of the most high has changed.
Now I understand why a translator would not really like
to put that in print
because the entire Bible tells us clearly that God
never changes, God does not change.
Amen. So why does the Bible say
God changes?
He says, this is the thing that is my grief.
What he's not saying is that God has changed
or that God would ever change.
But what he's describing is the temporary eclipse
of his soul that he's experiencing.
He feels like God has changed.
And if you can relate to that feeling, then you know exactly
what he's talking about.
That feels bad, right?
Like these are, this guy is a follower
of the Lord God Almighty, just as we are the followers
of the Lord Jesus Christ.
Even as you walk with God and trust him
and follow him, you can have moments
where you feel like this.
And if you feel like that, I guarantee you that
is a grief.
And so he's asking genuine questions.
He's expressing them, being honest and humble.
Which brings us to our next point, which is this,
which is really the major, some of the major
features here is that we are to remember things we're
to remember about God.
And the first is that we remember God's
faithfulness in our past.
Remember God's faithfulness in your past, read again, uh,
verses five and six kind of sets this up.
He says, I consider the days of old the years long ago.
I said, let me remember my song in the night.
Let me meditate in my heart.
And so he's calling to mind in his own experience.
I think times when he didn't feel like this, he's like, Hey,
there was a time I didn't feel like this.
There was a time the sun was out
and there wasn't this eclipse in my life.
And so he's remembering that it doesn't necessarily fix him,
but it does put him on the right path.
And then this is our next point. Do not wait to worship.
So often we're governed by our feelings
and our circumstances.
We're like, I worship God when I feel better.
But at the end, what we see here is Asaf begins here calling
to mind the goodness of God
entering into a posture of worship.
Two Corinthians five, chapter seven says, we walk by faith
and not by sight.
That means we live the Christian life by faith in the Son
of God, not by our temporary experiences.
In this context, we think about the Lord Jesus when he was
tempted and tested in the wilderness fasting
for 40 days and 40 nights.
And the enemy came to him
and tempted him, he said, man doesn't live
by bread alone, but what?
By every word that comes from the mouth of God.
In this context we might say, man doesn't live
by feelings alone.
We don't live the Christian life based on how we feel,
but we live it based on the fixed facts
and realities of who God is based on his eternal word.
Maybe you're familiar with the old illustration
of our lives being like a freight train
where the engine pulling the train is faith based on facts
and our feelings matter.
They're just way back in the caboose.
And as the train is making progress,
the feelings always come along.
But so often we want them backwards.
We're like, when I feel it, I'll get the engine going.
So don't wait to worship. You may not feel better.
You know, we have this thing called your final illness.
I've seen it on a death certificate.
It's the last thing that's gonna get me.
And so there's a day in which the darkness won't lift
and we will then us be ushered into the immediate presence
of God where it all goes away for eternity.
And so there's ways in which moments in which there's
darkness that we won't temporarily overcome,
but God always will.
We need to remember, don't wait to worship.
Our next point is that we remember again
what is true about God.
This is what ASF is about to do.
And he goes far beyond his own limited
thoughts and experience.
Uh, the questions from verses seven
to nine that he just ran through.
What we see is these become rhetorical questions.
They sort of get turned on his, on their head.
This is how he feels.
But he begins to realize that they have good answers.
When he asks the questions, he begins
to hear them coming back.
In truth, God will never spur forever.
He will again be favorable.
Lamentations three, his steadfast love will never cease.
His promises last forever.
His compassion is alive and well and will never forget.
He will always be gracious.
So we are called to remember these truths, to hold them,
to teach them to ourselves
and to one another, to preach them to ourselves.
We base our faith on fixed, settled, eternal truth,
facts and reality.
It's what pilots refer to as flying by the instruments.
So if a pilot is flying a plane through a cloud or a fog
or say at night and there's no light, it's actually possible
to be flying downward while feeling like
you're leveling off.
And and that's just a disaster waiting to happen.
But if a pilot flies by the instruments,
the instrument panel will tell him which way is up
or down and so forth.
So we fly by the instruments
because our visual cues, our, our experience
of reality can be skewed spiritually.
Speaking here is just kind of the burden of
what I wanna say this morning.
If you hear nothing else, I really wanna make this point.
This kind of faith that's fixed on eternal facts
that will carry you in life.
Whether you're in trouble in trial
or not, you will never be able to do this.
If you do not know your Bible,
like it is impossible for you to fly
by the instrument of God's word when you can't see
or sense reality, well,
you will never be able to do that.
Well if you do not know the Bible
and you say, you might say,
well the Bible's a big book, right?
Have you looked at it? I mean if I look here, this one,
it's got like thousands of pages.
What are we at? 1500 plus, right?
So what that means is that there's a lot of reading to do.
Uh, but the truth is, I,
if you're granted much time on earth, you've got a lot
of time to read it.
And so that's the beauty of this uh,
Asaf right here in this chapter.
He begins recalling, remembering, reciting
to himself the words of the Bible.
You know, Jesus was quoting the Bible,
he was quoting from Deuteronomy chapter eight,
I believe it was whenever he said, we don't live by uh,
bread alone, but by every word from the mouth of God.
If Jesus Christ needed to know
and to quote the Bible, how much more do you
and I need to meditate on God's word.
So we must consume God's word.
We live in a consumer society
and we're always like, oh, we don't wanna be consumers,
okay, but we want to be consumers of God's word.
We want to consume it like our life depends on it.
That means read it and know it.
If not, you're going to be, you will be malnourished,
stunted and hindered.
You'll be if you, your spirit's like a body,
you'd be starving.
And it's hard to do anything well with that.
So with God's word, you can feed your soul
and that fuels your faith.
Romans 15, four says,
for whatever was written in former days, including Psalm 77,
this was written for our instruction that through endurance
and through the encouragement of the scriptures, we might
have hope.
So read God's word. Listen to God's word.
Learn God's word.
Memorize God's word, become familiar with God's word.
Spend your whole life. It's like a lifelong pursuit
of getting acquainted with familiar with God's word.
And you say, well, I read and I don't remember everything.
I listen and it doesn't all sink in fine.
We do that with everything else.
So just start with God's word. Let it wash over you.
Let it seed and fertilize and season your mind
and you will find it.
Strengthening, encouraging, helping you everywhere you go,
every trial you face.
In verse 11, ASAP turns the corner here.
And um, and we read this as he continues, I will
remember the deeds of the Lord.
Yes, I will remember your wonders of old.
I will ponder all of your work
and meditate on your mighty deeds your way.
Oh God is holy. What? God is great like our God.
You are the God who works wonders.
You have made known your might among the peoples.
You with your arm redeemed your people, the children
of Jacob and of Joseph Sayah.
Listen to his holy resolve, his holy determination.
I will remember I love this quote by John Piper.
He says, we have to fight for our delight in God.
We tend to take our negative circumstances
and super impose them on God.
We interpret God based on our experiences rather than
looking at God and interpreting our experiences in light
of him and his eternal reality.
But here are the psalmist calls to mind the exodus
where the Israelites were pressed up against the sea.
They had their enemies on the one hand
and they had the ocean on the other.
There was no way out they could drown on the one hand
or be killed or enslaved on the other.
And what happened, not only did God stand between them
and the enemy and he hemmed them in,
but he did the unexpected.
There was no way out, but he delivered them.
He made a way by carving a path through the water
and he led them through on dry ground.
And then when the Egyptians pursued them,
the waters descended in a storm and a flood
and wiped out all their enemies.
Problem solved.
And this is one of the great
and awesome stories of the Bible that
resounds throughout both the old and the New Testament.
And he recounts it here at the end of verses 16 to the end.
When the waters saw you, oh God,
when the waters saw you, they were afraid.
Indeed, the deep tremble, the inanimate objects,
they responded to God.
The clouds poured out water, the skies gave forth thunder.
Your arrows flashed on every side.
The crash of your thunder was in the world.
When your lightings lighted up the world, the earth tremble
and shook your way was through the sea, your path
through the great waters.
Yet your footsteps were unseen.
You led your people like a flock by the hand
of Moses and Aaron.
You see the creation power of God on display.
You see his tender care like a shepherd.
Even when all that could be seen was the enemy
and the water and the storm.
God's footsteps were unseen.
God's right hand that seemed hard to see
was still invisible,
but the results became visible
as they were delivered from their impossible situation.
And in this we see not only do we see that today,
we can call that to mind.
I remember we can, when you read God's word,
you can remember the thousands of way God has intervened
to save and rescue his people.
But more than anything we have more than that.
There is the foreshadowing of the exodus story
that is carried out in the life and death
and resurrection of the Lord Jesus Christ,
where the whole world was subject to sin
and rebellion against God, enslaved to sin and death.
The Lord Jesus Christ, bit heaven and earth.
And he lived a perfect sinless life, something that you
and I could never do.
He died as a substitute in our place.
And then he rose again victorious over death hell in the
grave so that we might be made new as we trust in him
and that we might be with him forever.
Because Jesus Christ is the new and the better exodus.
Jesus Christ is the new and the better. Moses.
And we see this here being echoed in Psalm 77.
I'm about out of time. So let me do this quickly.
Our fourth point is this, that we need to rest in the Lord
who loves and leads you.
Matthew 1128 says, come to me all who labor
and are heavy laden and I will give you rest.
Take my yoke upon you, learn from me, for I am gentle
and lowly in heart.
And you will find rest for your soul.
Our fifth and final point is this, that you should remember
that it's not all about you.
The trials and troubles that come your way, they affect you.
There's a way in which it's about you,
but God is doing more than you can see or imagine.
And we need to remember He's doing something in us
and through us, an eternity will tell that story.
So in conclusion, sometimes our circumstances don't change
even when we cry out to God.
But what happens is that we change in the process.
Spiritual eclipses in our lives can be temporary,
localized experiences, but they strengthen us
and they stretch us and they grow our faith
like a good biblical lament.
We start where we are, but we're going somewhere.
And so that is God's word for us this morning.
So let me, I'd like to close in this way.
I mentioned this earlier, lamentation chapter three,
and I'd like to read this responsibly actually as we end.
So if you would do this with me, I would invite you
to actually please stand.
We're going to, I don't know if you're familiar
with lamentation three, uh, this portion of scripture.
Uh, if not, I would encourage you to memorize it,
to read it, sing it, pray it.
But lamentation chapter three, verses 21 to 26.
I'd like to read this responsibly.
I'll read first
and then if you would read, um, the next line.
God's word says this, this I call to mind and
therefore, I have hope
Today. I love
the Lord.
Good job. Just say it like you mean it.
His mercies never come to an end
Crate is your faithfulness.
The Lord Is my worship, my
Soul. Therefore,
I will hope in him.
The Lord is Good.
To the soul who seeks him in truth
Is good. Wait
rightly for salvation of Lord.